let's make a green smoothie part of the  morning routine so I've got spinach  pumpkin seeds blueberries some protein  powder from 22 days nutrition I'm gonna  do a little greens from juicero to add  to it  a little ginger some bee pollen some  tuna puree smooth elevator who doesn't  love a good mood elevator and some  omega-3s  essentially you're taking tons of plant  food  that's super nutrient dense to sit down  and actually eat everything that's in  here as if it was a salad would be  totally overwhelming especially in the  morning it's essentially pre-digested so  your body doesn't have to work very hard  taste test  actually tastes pretty good but it's how  it makes you feel that's the important  thing so